In 1959, the Tokaido Shinkansen line...
...started construction under Sogo's leadership.
Shima was appointed the project's chief engineer.
His team designed the sleek and revolutionary cone-shaped front,...
...from which the bullet train got its name.
Rather than being pulled by an engine in front,...
...each carriage of the bullet train...
...was driven by an individual electric motor,...
...which has proven to be safer, faster and more efficient.
Apart from the train itself, the team also built wider tracks,...
...which were more costly but allowed for greater stability and higher speeds.
Three thousand bridges and 67 tunnels were built on the 515-kilometer line...
...to allow a clear and largely curveless path.
Older trains were banned from the new line.
Equipped with advanced technologies,...
...the new trains were able to travel as fast as 210 kilometers per hour,...
...a breakthrough in the passenger rail industry...
...and the world's fastest at the time.
The journey time between Tokyo and Osaka was cut from over six hours to four.